>> Tucker: PRETTY UNEXPECTED
TWIST.
LITTLE ROCKET MAN WORKING
OUT.
FACE-TO-FACE MEETING BETWEEN
THE TWO LEADERS IF IT
HAPPENS IT WILL BE THE FIRST
SUMMIT BETWEEN A SITTING
AMERICAN PRESIDENT AND
DICTATOR FROM NORTH KOREA.
IN RESPONSE A LOT OF OUR
FOREIGN POLICY GENIUSES
MELTED DOWN.
>> I THINK FRANKLY IT'S A
DANGEROUS GAMBLE AND A BAD
IDEA.
APPEARED IN SOME WAYS I
CAN'T BELIEVE I'M SAYING
THAT BECAUSE FOR YEARS I
HAVE BEEN ARGUING THAT WE
NEED TO HAVE DIRECT TALKS
BETWEEN THE U.S. AND NORTH
KOREA.
>> I'M IN THE MORE OF THE HE
MUST BE KIDDING CAMP.
THE -- YOU KNOW, WE HAVE
JUST GIVEN KIM SOMETHING FOR
NOTHING.
>> BREATHTAKING GAMBLE FOR
ONE REPORT.
DO YOU AGREE.
IT'S A ROLL OF A NUCLEAR
DICE.
>> Tucker: ADVISOR TO
HILLARY CLINTON AND FORMER
DEPUTY SECRETARY OF STATE.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: I HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT THIS WILL LEAD TO IF
ANYTHING.
SEE IT GOING WRONG AND
TAKING UNEXPECTED AND
POSITIVE DIRECTIONS.
WHO KNOWS.
WHAT I KNOW FOR CERTAIN
EVERYBODY YOU JUST KNOW ON
TV IS DUMB.
HAS A LONG TRACK RECORD --
>> -- ONE OF THEM WAS MY
BEST FRIEND, ACTUALLY.
>> Tucker: I'M SURE.
EVERY ONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
HAS ADVOCATED FOREIGN POLICY
POSITIONS DISASTER FOR THE
UNITED STATES REPEATEDLY AND
NEVER CALLED TO ACCOUNT.
THE FACT THIS WAS UNEXPECTED
YESTERDAY SHOULDN'T SURPRISE
US.
WHY ARE WE STILL LISTENING
TO THESE PEOPLE.
>> I THINK IT WAS SURPRISING
EVERYBODY.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP
DEFINITELY HAS AN I TOLD YOU
SO IN HIM.
I THINK HE HAS A FAIR UP
I THINK HE HAS A FAIR NP
I THINK HE HAS A FAIR NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR HIM
TO SAY I TOLD YOU.
SO I DON'T THINK SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE MATTIS OR
SECRETARY OF STATE TILLERSON
SAW THIS COMING.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
>> OR THOUGHT THAT LANGUAGE
LAST YEAR, THE TWEETS WERE A
GOOD THING.
SO, WHAT HE DID, HE DID
INSTINCTIVELY ON HIS OWN.
TO THE EXTENT ESTABLISHMENT
GOT IT WRONG, IF THEY GOT IT
WRONG, WE WILL SEE IT'S NOT
PARTISAN.
>> Tucker: I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH YOU.
>> I HAVE ALWAYS THOUGHT
WHEN I WORKED FOR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, I HATED THE
WAY WE HANDLED NORTH KOREA.
I HATED THE WAY BUSH IT.
IT WAS ALWAYS TREATING THEM
LIKE THEY DESERVED TO BE
TREATED AS AN EQUAL.
I THOUGHT WE SHOULD JUST
IGNORE THEM.
I AT ONE POINT WANTED TO SAY
IF YOU CAN'T LAUNCH A ROCKET
THAT DOESN'T REACH, YOU
KNOW, THE OUTER ATMOSPHERE
WE ARE NOT GOING TO TALK
ABOUT YOU.
BUT, PRESIDENT TRUMP, YOU
KNOW, HE INHERITED SOMETHING
A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
HE INHERITED NORTH KOREA AT
A TIME WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
HARDER TO IGNORE.
THEY HAVE MADE, CLEARLY MADE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCES BOTH
IN THEIR MISSILES AND THEIR
BOMB STUFF AND HE, YOU KNOW,
SIX MONTHS AGO, I WOULD HAVE
TOLD YOU THAT IF WE WEREN'T
ALIVE IN A YEAR, NORTH KOREA
WOULD HAVE SOMETHING TO DO
WITH IT AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S BELLICOSE LANGUAGE.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF PEOPLE
FELT THAT WAY AND TO BE
FAIR, I JUST WANT TO BE
HONEST, YOU ARE RIGHT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE AT HIS OWN
STATE DEPARTMENT, THE
PRESIDENT'S OWN STATE
DEPARTMENT WOULD V.A. GREED
WITH YOU AFTER TWO DRINKS IN
PRIVATE FOR SURE.
MAYBE THE LESSON TO ALL OF
THIS IS YOU DON'T NEED TO
INSULT FOREIGN LEADERS MAYBE
EVIL ONES BUT THINK A LITTLE
MORE BROADLY.
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN DOING
ISN'T WORKING AND NOBODY IN
WASHINGTON IS WILLING TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BECAUSE
THEY ARE IMPLICATED IN PAST
BAD DECISIONS.
SHOULDN'T WE GO FORWARD WITH
MAYBE MORE OPEN MIND?
>> WE SHOULD.
AND, FRANKLY, I SURPRISED
THAT HE AGREED TO A MEETING
AND AGREED TO IT FAST.
TO THE EXTENT THAT OUR
DIPLOMACY IS SLOW AND
PLOTTING AND DOESN'T WORK,
MIGHT AS WELL BLOW IT UP.
WE COULD BE SITTING HERE IN
SIX MONTHS AND TALK ABOUT
HOW THIS WAS WAS AN ABSOLUTE
DEBACLE.
YOU FOCUSED ON IMMIGRATION
AND TIMES IN THE LAST MONTH
YOU HAVE NOT LIKED WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID IMMIGRATION.
REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS NOT
LIKED WHAT THEY HEAR FROM
HIM, INCLUDING ON TV.
THIS IS GOING TO BE PRETTY
SIMILAR.
I MEAN, NOT THAT IT WILL BE
ON TV OR LET'S ALL HOPE IT
WILL BE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS HERE FOR
AMERICA WE'RE ALL ONE AT
THIS POINT BECAUSE IF KIM
DOES SOMETHING CRAZY, HE IS
GOING TO BLOW US UP
IRRESPECTIVE OF WHAT PARTY
WE ARE PART OF.
BUT YOU HAVE THE SOUTH
KOREANS.
YOU HAVE THE JAPANESE.
YOU HAVE THE CHINESE.
AND I KNOW YOU ARE ALWAYS
VERY INTERESTED IN THE
CHINESE.
THIS IS A PROBLEM.
IF HE GOES IN THERE AND HE
SAYS I'M A GREAT DEALMAKER,
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT WHAT
DEALS HE HAS MADE IN HIS
LIFE.
HE TENDS TO OVERPAY.
IF HE OVERPAYS FOR THIS
DEAL, THEN SOMEONE IS GOING
TO SUR.
AND IT'S PROBABLY GOING TO
BE SOMEONE OTHER THAN US BUT
KIM JONG UN IS NOT.
>> Tucker: I AGREE.
THIS IS COMPLEX.
WHAT WE KNOW IS THAT
PREVIOUS STRATEGIES FAILED,